>> Bill: PICKING UP STEAM AS
THE DAY GOES ON, PROTEST AND
MORE CITIES AS STATES PUSH TO
REOPEN, SOME IN CALIFORNIA
CALLING THE GOVERNOR TO GET A
BACK UP AND RUNNING AFTER YOU
CLOSE THE BEACHES IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
PROTESTERS ARE DEMANDING AN END
TO THE STAY-AT-HOME ORDER,
PROTESTERS ON BOTH DATES.
HUNTINGTON BEACH, CALIFORNIA.
WILLIAM.
>> WELL, HERE IN CALIFORNIA YOU
CAN MEDITATE, TREAT TIME, GOLF,
GET YOUR BOTOX COMING OR
ALCOHOL.
THE ONE THING YOU CANNOT DO IS
GO ON THAT BEACH.
BUT IT IS WIDELY IGNORED AND NOT
ENFORCED.
THAT IS STILL THE REASON WHY
PEOPLE ARE PROTESTING.
LOOKING AT 1,000 PEOPLE SAYING
THAT THEY SEE A PATCH WORK OF
RULES AND ENFORCEMENT, WHY?
GOVERNOR NEWSOM SAID THAT HIS
OFFICE PLANNED TO CLOSE
840 MILES OF BEACH.
THE ENTIRE COASTLINE.
THEN IN THE AFTERNOON HE
REVERSED COURSE CLOSING ONLY ONE
ORANGE COUNTY.
>> SOME OF THOSE BEACHES HAVE
RAISED ALARM BELLS, PEOPLE THAT
WERE NOT PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING.
WE WILL DO A HARD CLOSE IN THAT
PART OF THE STATE, JUST IN
ORANGE COUNTY AREA.
>> IT IS A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF
UNNECESSARY GOVERNMENT
OVERREACH.
HIS ACTIONS ARE UNNECESSARY AND
CAPRICIOUS.
AND IT IS AN ACT OF RETRIBUTION
AGAINST ORANGE COUNTY.
>> LOCAL SAY THAT HE IS
PUNISHING ORANGE COUNTY BASED ON
A FEW PHOTOS THAT SHOW PACKED
BEACHES LAST WEEKEND, COMPARE
THOSE TO THESE.
IN NEWPORT BEACH POLICE SAY ON
SATURDAY THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKED
LIKE.
PEAK HOURS, 2:00 P.M., PAINTING
A DIFFERENT PICTURE.
DEPUTIES AND LIFEGUARDS SAY THAT
THEY HONOR THE 6-FOOT BUFFER AND
WHEN ASKED, THEY WERE COMPLIANT
TO MOVE.
LOCAL SAY THEY ARE NEITHER
IGNORANT OF THE RULES OR
RECKLESS.
>> EVERYTHING IS SHUT DOWN.
LEAVE THE WATER TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ENJOYING IT.
>> HEALTHY FOR US TO BE OUT IN
THE WATER.
AND WE KEEP OUR DISTANCE.
>> WE WANT TO BE SAFE, BUT WE
WANT TO BE FREE.
WE CANNOT GIVE UP OUR FREEDOM
FOR SAFETY.
>> GUIDED BY SCIENCE AND DATA,
BUT ORANGE COUNTY HAS LOWER
RATES OF INFECTION,
HOSPITALIZATION, AND FATALITY
THAN THE NEIGHBORING COUNTIES.
SO 19 TIMES MORE LIKELY TO GET
TO THIS VIRUS AND OUT.
NOW THE CITIES OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH AS WELL AS DATA POINTS
HAVE FIRED THE LAWSUIT LATER
THIS AFTERNOON CHALLENGING THE
CLOSURES OF THE BEACHES.
AS YOU CAN SEE, PEOPLE ARE OUT
THERE, THEY ARE SURFING.
PEOPLE ARE SITTING AND SO FORTH.
THEY ARE GOING ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS.
BUT AS FAR AS ENFORCEMENT IS
CONCERNED, RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
NOT DOING IT HERE IN NEWPORT